and I'm going to send it down I'm very
relaxed
I could have extension just a matter
that I angle just it still goes down
okay but you all find it easier
you guys keep with you you'll find it
easier if you push out in this alignment
and have a symmetric
a little more time we want you to play
with it okay I want you to move it
around without have it you're a little
more advanced I went to the top so I can
tell it is not straining cheese egg
multi width thing come out choose weird
angles then she'd be on her way but it's
not
a racial way of
finding them oh but you have to do this
I think that's why if you look at the
historical text they didn't answer that
question in academically like we asked
it how do you do it they described it
poetically or we call artistically and I
think a lot of people think that that's
because it was code when you get out
I think it was because it was beyond the
academic or intellectual sequencing or a
linear mapping I also they also relied
on the mentor relationship okay so when
you when you do this I have to I find
that over the years I am still using
poetic means even though I might
describe what I'm doing so I might go
okay take your pelvis and curl it
slightly up okay because this this is
wrong this is a bracing angle on my
lower back you see and if he's strong
enough it starts to weaken okay so you
tell the student put your publicist
until pelvis up but then they go like
this and what happened my center of
gravity shifts to the back so even
though you're describing it with
anatomical terms I'm really just trying
to describe a feeling that I have what
we do get them in I find that you might
get better results if I don't tell you
turn your pelvis up right but instead if
I tell you try to pop your chest try to
explode your body
or try to break your belt or as we've
said before be a bear imagine you're a
big bear okay so let's see where you get
with that first the expand think
expanding things okay don't let what I
find happens is that the grip steals the
mind and you become the small thing see
you start to just go like this small but
deep things don't care about the grip I
don't care where I am I'm as big as this
room see where we know what you're doing
with your hands okay so we we have had
enough studies and tell us you know we
adopt the posture of a defeated posture
our mood will top that idea if we we
have done it in Reverse when you guys
are super exhausted and about to vomit
I say you to start smiling and
everyone's able to do a lot more extra
reps because their mind shifts okay
so the posture first of all is crown of
the head is the high point so I can't do
this doesn't have the crown of this
month of high point so it's not even
though I ponder but I I can tell you how
to drop your head like
this is your giving over to this thing
so keep keep your keep your posture
light like you keep pushing the whole
time right like you're doing like you're
doing the Gaza and you're just here and
he doesn't exist right and then you go
ahead John that's a new one
nothing's really changing you think you
can do this just here here okay this
right push my hardest come on right if I
if I like if I let that go like nothing
that you know if I like that go my
definitely there's no way you can do
that holy that's too you see you got to
not be in your dumpling
you got you got to not be done okay
because tactically the corners of your
shoulders are weak points they take
power away from your strikes so when you
hit like this the assumption of power is
that it's not going to because you can
see how much movement there is you see
that not only the rotation of the arm
but the scapula and then all the ribs so
forest is kind of not come back it's got
a hit as the unit boom okay it's just
one solid thing oh so it's not just a
parlor trick
it's the body unification test is what
it is so if I if I isolate a muscle
group which is what I do when I use a
muscle group then when I hit something
or throw something it starts to give way
it start to absorb force it doesn't go
into the target okay try to get
we're using the those poetics because
we've gone over the anatomical position
we've discussed it a million times I
just don't think it's the only way of
learning it okay so that's what we're
trying this but what we want when up
when I do this I don't really have a
connection okay I don't have a mutual
relationship either out of a
victimization okay so really what I want
to do is reach out so that when I move
he he moves I I got a connection going
you see that and yet it's not
necessarily for fighting but it's a tool
that I do use in fight okay the tool is
how do I enter into a relationship with
you okay so yeah I can get you into a
relationship with my techniques like
this
he's not moving when I'm moving hey a
cure I already have established this
where we're one so when I move he moves
[Music]
and this same relationship continues
here I still have that same you
what you have to do is to get is you
can't so he expands okay he's he's got
me so just wiggle around and see that
I'm good
you see okay as you can when he when
he's got me and he Wiggles
I can't disconnect see I I don't have
those on then punched in them
okay they were not training so same
thing goes when he goes on with the
technique I have that same relationship
with it's not he goes yeah yeah broke
broke so he's training for it I'm
training for it it's not it's not a
fighting architecture it's a cultivation
of a skill okay so
when I grab in safety I don't drop them
tiny I drop on the baby
let's go so again big hit the connection
boom connection ok I'm in the same thing
so as I'm here I'm going to take that
same dynamic stillness and now move it
big boom ok and then big wherever you're
touching it doesn't matter right
as as I go on because that was where the
throw was right then I can hit him and
he won't be there I'll touch him but I
won't break his ribs okay so I have the
same body relationship to the ground to
my internal structure and I create a
relationship with him
boom then I'm going to use it to move
him well and now I'm going to use the
tune in to and I can throw pretty good
with that structure because he's not
really there because he got projected
out by the bottom man you guys
understand boom so all you people who
then show arm collapse you're not gonna
like that technique because that means
that I'm getting close to deal with the
punch
I'm rejecting him he just has a vested
interest in keeping that check so you
don't get any more projection if he
lifts his arm and he'll drag the
projection of Cooper do you understand
but then we're not training okay so I'm
here all right he has that basic
technique it's a good one
big Auster imagining
and he's going to experience the fall in
the unified way
hey so he doesn't let his arms moving in
now he keeps the posture and I keep the
posture and when I bow my display
okay listen hey haven't notice I started
I live over here and and now just had
this thought just goes yet okay because
it wasn't really in the hands and how is
just put it okay it's in it's in here
nobody touches I'm already in there and
now I have this connection you see
that's the one I pushed
okay I'm gonna now go yet again are you
gonna keep your punch him in the face
he breaks connection with his body this
is this lock below and I'll punch him in
the face okay cool now right into his
body I'm still throwing in DC I still
going here this one's going in you see
that so he's United his heads move boom